due to a personal matter
paloma will no longer
paloma will no longer be continuing in
the big brother games
big brother season 24 contestant paloma
aguilar exits the house before the live
eviction we always say expect the
unexpected and that is the beauty of
this show host julie chen kicked off
thursday's episode with that exact line
teasing a big change as you know our
motto has always been expect the
unexpected and that tonight could not be
more true
but an unexpected turn of events has now
changed everything but before anything
was announced the show explained how
paloma suffered from anxiety and was
getting just two to four hours of sleep
a night i hope these cameras are off at
this point because i want some privacy
i'm serious
i physically cannot sleep in this house
i'm exhausted eventually head of
household daniel durston called everyone
into the living room to read an
announcement delivered by producers due
to a personal matter
paloma will no longer
paloma will no longer be continuing in
the big brother game
she wanted to pass along that she loves
you all and wishes you all the best
thanks guys but paloma's exit had fans
suspicious online there had already been
some controversy surrounding the cast's
behavior toward fellow house guest
taylor hale particularly comments made
by paloma who from the start made it
clear she wasn't exactly taylor's
biggest fan so my name is taylor i'm 27
i'm from detroit michigan former beauty
queen passed that title on about a month
ago i wouldn't even have said i was a
pageant girl because that's just
associated with the ability to be fake i
would like to say that
the us has 50 states
and it's like so robotic yeah and ahead
of the season 24 premiere paloma told et
who she predicted she'd clash with the
most i really do get annoyed with people
that are like overtly chatty and just
like loud and obnoxious
but nonetheless i'll act like i like
them
and also people that are two-faced like
i can catch on to that very quickly so
um yeah they'll be out in no time fans
were outraged over how taylor was
treated by the house guests some
accusing them of bullying her and
spreading lies
i want to know what's going on with the
boys they're so close we need to split
them up
if she is going to try and ruin my game
that's not going to fly with me and that
resulted in the former beauty queen
being put up on the block it has come to
my attention though that you've been
rubbing the house the wrong way a little
bit and what's good for the house is
good for my long-term game
so you're in the position now where you
can rally for votes and maybe even
apologize for some things you've said in
this house because of paloma's early
exit the first twist and eviction were
cancelled which is good news for taylor
and fellow block nominee terence higgins
they're safe for another week but don't
think there won't be more twists ahead
julie gave e.t a hint of what to expect
this season i'm not asking you to give
it away but just give us a little hint
our challenges are next level this
season this competition
new competitions i mean
people who were like real gamers you
know back in the day maybe season six
seven eight it's a whole new game yeah i
don't know if those people would do as
well today it it's so much harder big
brother this year more than ever
[Music]
you